[Music]
recently there's been a lot of policy
interest in so-called soda taxes and in
the US several cities have started
implementing such taxes and quite a few
other cities are thinking about whether
to pass such taxes and if they pass them
how to exactly implement them how high
to set the tax rate over which
geographic area to levy the tax and
which products should exactly fall under
the tax and so we were interested in
using data from one of the cities that
already implemented such attacks in
order to understand exactly how the
attacks affected consumers whether to
improve nutritional intake whether it
was able to raise tax revenue and to use
those findings to then guide our
thinking about how to design soda taxes
going forward in our study we're using
data from Philadelphia which is the
first largest city that implemented such
a soda tax and it provides us with very
detailed information across many
products and a large set of stores
starting from convenience stores to
supermarkets to wholesale clubs and we
observe both the prices and the
quantities that were purchased of sugar
sweetened beverages before and after the
tax went into effect
a Philadelphian our mind was a
particularly useful testbed to look at
the effects of soda taxes and think
about what effect soda taxes might have
in other localities so far
researchers have mainly used data from
Berkeley where the first soda tax was
introduced in order to study the effects
of such attacks but Berkeley is a
relatively small place relatively
homogeneous and so it's a bit of a
question to what extent those findings
would extrapolate to other settings
Philadelphia instead is much closer to
the US average in terms of its
demographic profile in terms of its
obesity rate and it's also quite
heterogeneous and diverse City so it
allows us to study how consumers in
different neighborhoods with different
income profiles and different obesity
rates might react to the tax
this tax was 1.5 cents per ounce so on
the typical two-liter bottle of coke the
price would increase from about a dollar
fifty to two dollar and fifty so that's
a very substantial increase in prices
now the tax was levied not on retailers
directly but on distributors so first
thing to study is whether the price
increase was actually passed through to
consumers and we find that the answer to
that question is yes it is essentially a
hundred percent pass the rate
we find that quantity purchased in
stores in Philadelphia drops quite
dramatically by about 46% on average
which sometimes even larger decreases in
supermarkets and some somewhat smaller
decreases in convenience stores to tend
to sell smaller pack size of goods
we study in particular to adjustment
margins we looked at do people switch to
untaxed beverages and has really two
classes of beverages here people could
switch to bottled water or they could
switch to natural juices which aren't
taxed because they have no artificial
sweetener added to them interestingly we
find there's almost no change in demand
for bottled water so that doesn't seem
to be that doesn't seem to be any
substitution towards those products and
there's some modest amount of
substitution to its natural juices which
are presumably healthy along other
dimensions but they actually still quite
high in sugar and calories so it doesn't
improve things along that dimension and
then finally and this is maybe the most
interesting and striking finding that we
didn't necessarily anticipate is that we
see a large amount of what we call cross
shopping a lot of consumers drive
outside of the city in order to buy the
same beverages at stores that aren't in
the text area now it's important to bear
in mind that Philadelphia is still a
relatively small area so you're never
more than four miles away from the city
border so it's maybe just quite easy to
engage in that type of cross shopping
and so about half of the decrease that
we see in stores in Philadelphia is
compensated by a corresponding increase
in stores up to six miles outside of the
city border
interestingly what we find is that
stores that are located in lower-income
areas there's actually less of a
response to the price increase and this
was something that initially was very
surprising to us because you would think
that lower-income households tend to be
more price sensitive now one possible
explanation for that is that low-income
households have less access to transport
so it's harder for them to cross shop at
stores outside of the city and hence
they can't react on that particular
adjustment margin and so what happens is
that they simply continue buying the
product at the higher price
whereas richer households drive outside
of the city to buy this soda at those
stores where the tax does not apply
the fact that so many consumers decided
to drive outside of the city to buy
sugar sweetened beverages is a
discouraging fact along a few different
dimensions so what this large amount of
Cross shopping means is that we don't
get an improvement in nutritional intake
because consumers continue to buy the
same products it leads to lower tax
revenue because purchases outside of the
city aren't taxed and to inconveniences
consumers in the process so regardless
of whether you're aiming at improving
consumers nutritional intake or you're
trying to raise tax revenue that you can
use for other purposes in the city the
Cross shopping makes it harder to
achieve both of those goals
depending on the policy goal you have
whether you want to improve nutritional
intake or simply raise tax revenue you
might adjust policy Devers a little bit
differently if you want to raise tax
revenue you want to make it very
difficult for consumers to avoid the tax
so what you want to do is to tax a broad
geographic area and to have a broad
product coverage so it's difficult for
consumers to substitute to any other
product in either Geographic or product
space if instead you're trying to
improve nutritional intake you want to
make it hard for consumers to avoid the
tax geographically but you actually do
want them specifically to substitute to
its different products in particular
healthier ones and so if you're trying
to improve nutritional intake my
suggestion would be to tax a broader
geographic area but tax a more narrow
range of products that actually allows
consumers to substitute too it's
relatively healthier products
[Music]